I came to Dubai for the first time 5 years ago.
I
hated it. I thought how could you
go to Dubai and I
was in Sri Lanka myself at the time.
Suddenly a bad attack
happened on Ayurveda. I was one of the last
Germans to get out  and because
I protected the people and
said I don't want to go home with this energy,
I'll stay there and
then I said where can I go now on the
way from Sri Lanka back to
Germany, I want to process it first
and I landed in Dubai  and
found a place there and
then I stayed there for a long time and got to
know the country, people, tradition in a completely different way, got to know the locals,
which simply gave me a
new horizon in life and
then I also saw wow Dubai is a
great marketplace
People